Ну я не можу назвати якогось органу
правоохоронного органу який би ми могли
назвати абсолютно незалежним на жаль це
вже
Ані Служба безпеки України Ані звичайно
МВС Ані дбр очевидно що за результатами
перших кроків нового керівника набу
Будемо бачити його наскільки служимо є
зауваження до нього але в будь-якому
випадку справді ми є свідками такої
тенденції коли оця розгалужена система
правоохоронних органів зокрема такі
спеціалізуються на боротьбі з корупцією
суть яких якраз і полягала в тому щоб
вони були е-е політично незалежними
поступово крок за кроком ця політична
незалежність фактично ліквідовується і
на жаль це загроза для нормального
демократичного розвитку України на жаль
це те що Чим нам доведеться боротися вже
навіть після перемоги у цій війні для
того щоб країна повернулася на
нормальний демократичний шлях розвитку і
на жаль це все дуже пов'язано з цією
першою частиною нашої розмовою як коли
говорили про
якусь спробу або контролю інформаційного
поля не завжди доречно спробував
контроль інформаційного поля Тобто ми
бачимо якусь концентрацію влади і
обмеження
пов'язані якраз з інформаційному полі
тобто через цей так званий єдиний
марафон ми бачимо коли
правоохоронні органи зокрема і тільки
зобов'язанням процес з корупцією
беруться під контроль і очевидно що це
все ну загрожує для демократичного
розвитку України більш того знаєте от є
ситуація
скандальна ситуація з колишнім
керівником служби безпеки України паном
бакановам От коли всі теж закрили очі
при можливо очі на те що Ok йому не
Професіонал але президент має право
призначити на цю посаду нібито людину
яка йому особисто найбільш вірна яка їм
для нього є особисто найбільш близькою
відтак президенти будує йому має
довіряти суспільством і ми бачимо чим це
закінчується Ця історія тобто
імовірність того що пана баканова
звинувачують у державній зраді і
причетності до тих страшних дій які мали
місце під час повномасштабного
російського наступу кажуть що
недостатньо буде просто хорошим другом
президента для того щоб виконувати
професійно свої обов'язки і більш того
для того щоб бути готовим протистояти
російській агресії
якщо ми говоримо про баканова тому що
сказав в такому в
продовжераюсь до слів Володі я просто
про інші проблема якраз у тому що Влада
сказала що ця справа засекречена тобто є
є якесь розслідування але результати
розслідування вам шановне суспільство не
розкажемо і на цьому крапка тобто якраз
у цьому пробле вже навіть сам сам факт
про звільнення голови служби безпеки за
статтею дисциплінарного статуту який по
суті передбачає фактично державну зраду
це дуже вже багато про що говорить і
справді зважаючи на обставини звільнення
Мені здається що тут контроль
суспільства інформація яка очевидно
дозовано має подаватися на воєнний стан
Але тим не менше має подаватися що
робиться з цією справою ну мали би це
отримувати тому що дуже небезпечно коли
незрозуміло що робиться і з цим мова